I'm Shelby Holliday and I'm here with
Major General Joseph Ryan commander of
the Army's 25th Infantry Division and we
are here in the Luzon Strait so just to
get viewers oriented that is north of
the Philippines main island of Luzon and
just south of Taiwan Major General
thanks for being here thanks for having
us here my pleasure what message does
the US's presence in the Luzon Straits
send to allies and potential adversaries
in the region what it means is we are
going to operate and train and partner
with our allies and partners in the
region especially those who are our
treaty allies like the Philippines has
been since 1951 and what our presence
shows here is a commitment it's a
commitment to ensuring that their
desire for sovereignty is something that
they can count on us to help them attain
and maintain China has militarized a
number of islands in the South China Sea
right what kind of threat does that pose
to your troops and your partners in the
Philippines
well it certainly is something we're
keeping an eye on China has decided on
some level that they are going to make
the rules and they are not going to
abide by the international rules-based
order that has been in place here for
the last 75 years since the end of World
War II a rules-based order in fact that
has helped them grow and Thrive into the
economic Powerhouse and world power that
they are
um
and that's that's troubling it's
troubling for the Philippines it's
troubling for Australia it's troubling
for Japan all all of which are treaty
allies of the United States of America
the United States of America is a
Pacific Power as well it's troubling to
all of us
we simply want to understand in at on
some level
why the Chinese are acting this way why
they are deciding that now that the
international rules-based order that
benefits all
is not in their best interests of course
um we don't know why that is exactly
because we're not really communicating
well with them right now I know there
are many in the U.S government who would
like to engage the PRC on this
particular topic and we're open to the
dialogue when they're ready to have it
the call is out there it's absolutely
out there it's out there on several
levels
and and we're ready for that dialogue
and and I think I think it's important
to have that dialogue so we can
de-escalate uh because because right now
there's opportunities for escalation
that probably don't don't need to be
there the X size we are here to
specifically observe is an air assault
can you walk us through what that looks
like what the mission is what it is an
air assault operation is designed to
provide positional advantage through
ownership and occupation of terrain so
we are using some of the many islands in
the Philippine chain here in the Luzon
Straits to demonstrate our capability to
conduct aerosol operations both from
Land forces to another position on land
we've also conducted an operation off of
this ship here the USS Miguel Keith
with embarked forces to one of the
islands here in the in the Philippine
chain to the north of Luzon and this
island is a couple hundred miles from
Taiwan it is it is it is one of the
northernmost points in the in the
Philippine chain here in the Luzon
Straits yes in the event of a conflict
over Taiwan how strategically important
is this island and the islands around it
very important I mean again uh geography
matters the Philippines sits where it
sits
um I think there's uh there's certainly
a sense that
should conflict occur in Taiwan that the
Philippines would be affected as as
would Japan
as would several other nations bordering
the South China Sea and in this area of
the world you mentioned the Philippines
as a treaty Ally if the Philippines is
attacked the U.S is obligated to defend
it that's right how difficult is it to
defend and fight on that kind of
territory well I mean again defending
defending everywhere is defending
nowhere
so we certainly wouldn't
try to do that
um we would we first off most
importantly is we respect our Philippine
Partners sovereignty
uh part of this exercise and what it's
grown to
from the Philippine side
is a recognition that the defense of the
Philippines is important to them when I
was here two years ago we weren't
discussing this particular aspect uh of
of of
training because it wasn't something
that they were necessarily overly
concerned about
it's clearly something that they are now
yeah well um
they've recognized that something's
changed and therefore we want to help
them
with what they want to do so this is not
about the United States coming to the
Philippines and exercising
what we want to do on their terrain and
I know there's some concern internal to
the Philippines about what this
expansion of uh
of these uh enhanced defense cooperation
agreements sites are and mean for the
relationship between the Philippines and
the United States here in the
Philippines what does the U.S plan
well you know this the difference the
difference really between
a site that's been designated as an
enhanced defense cooperation agreement
site versus one that hasn't
we can we train in both places with the
Philippine Army we absolutely do
the edcites allow us to do a little bit
more in terms of developing
infrastructure that helps in concert
with not just what the Philippine
government and the Philippine Army needs
but what we may need I think one of the
concerns that or one of the phrases that
I've heard is the U.S could use these
bases as staging grounds against China
is that what they are
well I I think I think you could
feasibly see that they are but
we wouldn't do any of that without the
consent of the Philippine government
right and and we really don't have a
reason to Stage for operations against
China because China is a free and
Sovereign Nation and as long as they act
within the international based
rules-based order here in the region
they have plenty of room to operate and
do what they choose to do
certainly within their own Sovereign
territory
um I think the question becomes when we
have disputed
territory uh and how they act in the
region with territory that is also
claimed by other Sovereign Nations there
have been International
rulings right that have designated that
terrain as belonging to the Philippines
or belonging to Vietnam right and yet
the Chinese don't seem to want to it's
not unique to the
it's not at all unique to the
Philippines there's several countries
that have claims to islands in the South
China Sea that that the PRC have decided
they're not going to respect those
claims
so
that's a part of the problem is the lack
of dialogue is the lack of cooperation
the lack of involvement the lack of will
to entertain the idea that they're not
the only country operating out here and
so I think it's gotten it's gotten
several of these nations nervous
um
and I think
in large part
several of these nations have then
decided Well we
we we our security partner of choice
is the United States of America and so
there's a void to fill here that
not only do we want to help them fill
but we're obligated to help many of them
fill through our mutual defense treaties
China the PRC has been very vocal about
its opposition to the Edgar sites and to
the US's strengthening relationships
China says that the U.S wants to contain
it is that what the US is trying to do
no no I and and and I can unequivocally
say there is there again there is room
for China in the international
rules-based order here in the Pacific
and globally and we need to open up a
dialogue right now right now that's
what's most troubling is the lack of
dialogue I think so I think so we don't
want a war with China nobody wants that
the last thing we want certainly me as a
soldier last thing I want is a conflict
with the People's Republic of China it
will not be good for anybody not be good
for any of us
that said we we that doesn't
that doesn't dilute or or
um
doesn't it doesn't distract me from
doing my job
which is to deter conflict from
occurring
to keep it from happening
and then if it does happen to be trained
and prepared to fight it
that's my job best prepared to fight
absolutely and that's what we're doing
here I mean I couldn't be prouder about
being here on a Navy ship
operating with a with several of our
greatest allies in the region the
Filipinos and and the Australians uh and
executing training with them in
Philippine Sovereign territory
uh it's just making us better it's
making us all better
so and it's helping us prepare for
whatever contingencies arise
because the relationships that we build
the interoperability that we build the
familiarity that we build it goes a long
way
the asymmetric advantage of our
alliances and Partnerships in the region
is part of what separates us from the
PRC because they don't have that the
relationships they don't have the
relationships and it's the Envy it's
really the Envy of the entire world when
you look at it how we're able to build a
coalition of allies and partners in the
region when there's trouble look at
what's happened in Ukraine
that said
Partnerships and alliances and
coalitions don't win Wars
combat credible forces
Allied
and together
win Wars so if conflict happens I'm
confident we're prepared to fight it how
so you know Shelby that's a great
question
um
we're sitting here in the Luzon Straits
on a Navy ship you know and I can't see
any land
with the naked eye from where we sit
certainly it would be different from the
standpoint of we have to be able to
project power
in a
theater that involves a significant
amount of Maritime terrain the sea
the distances that we talk about here
are vast we can put all of the continent
of Europe Plus
into the South China Sea essentially so
the distances are vast
but in the end Shelby and especially
where I come from in the 25th Infantry
Division war is about uh the will to
fight and win between armed adversaries
on land and it's about the last hundred
meters and
um we have to be prepared to fight in
this terrain whether it be on Sea in the
air or on the land and all the domains
undersea in cyber and in space as well
we have to be prepared to do it all
and the United States and our allies and
partners hold significant advantages
over the PRC today in many of those
domains right now if not all of them
there's certainly there's certainly
China's military buildup IS astonishing
it's uh
uh to some it's impressive
um
it's something we have to keep an eye on
and it's not showing any signs of
slowing down it's not showing any signs
of slowing down in many cases it's
accelerating beyond what we're doing
there's no question about that why
so the South China Sea is clearly a
strategic Maritime area of the world
where
uh it's sort of centrally located
between nations that
um
are home to six out of every 10 people
on earth
probably soon enough it'll be seven out
of every ten
um
a an
incredible amount of the world's com
Commerce transits through the South
China Sea the Luzon Straits the Malacca
Straits the Taiwan Straits
this area of the world is incredibly
valuable from an economic standpoint
alone in terms of the amount of goods
that that pass through here and the
amount of uh people that pass through
here on ships on planes moving from one
place to another
economic powerhouses like Singapore like
Hong Kong
we talked about Manila Jakarta Tokyo
Taipei these are huge populous
Advanced industrial cities that
um
are incredibly important to the to the
rest of the world
so
it's it's it's important to the United
States for that
but it's also important to the United
States I think fundamentally because
of
the value of sovereignty in the Nations
that operate
here that are here do you see a nato in
a
it's certainly a viable concept
whether there's a nato in the Pacific I
think depends on the nations in the
Pacific that would make up that type of
structure
um
it could you could certainly see
something coming out of some of the
bodies that exist here but
um that's certainly a uh it's certainly
an idea that I think has some Merit
um
because right now we operate on uh at
least the United States operates here on
a number of uh
uh country to Country Mutual defense
treaties
and we'd certainly like to see more
cooperation among nations
a commitment to come to their age should
they need help and that's really what
NATO is that's what that's what NATO's
been
pre-conflict uh that's what NATO is now
with
conflict happening on its borders
it can be a very valuable arrangement